when settling into a new home one of the
key things you want to have is fast
reliable and secure home internet well
Verizon the sponsors of this next
segment has the solution and so much
more here to tell us more is Heidi
flatto welcome to the show hello it's
great to have you here thanks for having
me so many great gadgets to start with
but let's talk about the key thing you
need Wi-Fi in your house what do you
guys have you do and you know when you
move you've got all kinds of things to
worry about and figuring out what what
provider you want to go with is a hassle
we want to like eliminate so Verizon
home internet is a great solution for
that couldn't be easier you just plug it
in and you'll get fast reliable and
secure internet and it's you know it I
think it's just the greatest most simple
solution to solve that problem it's it's
one of the best we have it in our house
and my wife has we have a setup
downstairs in her office and upstairs in
the bedroom no issue streaming anything
Zoom calls are fantastic so this is a
great setup very strong Wi-Fi yeah it's
great and right now if you sign up today
you'll will get a 200 Home Depot gift
card wow Verizon okay that will help you
with your other moving stuff that you're
dealing with
um and so that's with Verizon home
internet 5G home internet plus perfect
and now moving on so it's summertime
maybe you want to have a watch a movie
outside this is really cool what do you
have yes and for those of you moving
into a new house you'll be the head of
the neighborhood so this is the Samsung
freestyle projector so you can stream
movies your shows uh a slideshow
whatever you want either indoors or out
you can hang a sheet in the backyard and
have outdoor movie night it's so fun
it's got 360 premium sound to it and it
just it's really a fun thing to have not
everybody this thing is great to
entertain the kids or make a movie night
outside or project it on a wall yeah
that's fantastic in the remote control
to control everything as well okay
summertime backyard barbecues yes what
do you got for us well you got to have
music right yes I mean it's not a party
without music so the JBL pulse 5
Bluetooth speaker is really a great
device it's got as you can see this
beautiful a light show going on and
really great sound it's waterproof and
dust proof and it also I was playing
with it last night and it'll play
Ambient sound so if you want to have
hear crickets or a Babbling Brook uh the
ocean yes uh that kind of thing so it
maybe you're doing a camp out in your
living room you're watching movies you
can have the sound of crickets inside
exactly this is great too for the
traveler like my wife and I we like a
sound machine we want some kind of white
noise when we sleep so we can take that
with us when we travel now speaking of
traveling one of my fears is leaving my
house unattended yes and you have the
solution yes so the nest doorbell is
battery powered Wireless couldn't be
easier to install and with the app you
can really pay attention to what's going
on at your house 24 7 you'll have access
to it on your smartphone you can get
alerts if you're expecting a package
you'll get an alert when that will pop
up on your phone yes so that'll really
give you peace of mind that's awesome
what's it called again that is the
Google Nest doorbell and that's
streaming 24 7 you're getting the video
that you need up front yes I'm on the
app on your smartphone wherever you go
perfect Heidi all of this stuff is
fantastic let's talk about Verizon plans
that you have to offer about 30 seconds
so excited we just announced my plan
which is revolutionizing Wireless plans
so you get to pick what you want only
pay for what you need and it just
couldn't be more customizable you're not
locked into any contracts you can change
your plan at any time everybody in the
family can get the the plan they want
and the perks that they need you just
said something that you normally don't
hear when it comes to a cell phone
provider customizable what you need you
guys will offer absolutely I love it
thank you so much Eddie thank you for
joining us and thank you to Verizon for
sponsoring this segment switching to
Verizon home internet is the easiest
part of your move cut the cable and
switch to Verizon home internet today
for more information visit verizon.com
forward slash 5G home and we will be
right